je laisse nos invités s'installer
peut-être vous dire
avant de leur donner la parole que
l'audition de ce matin est retransmise
sur le en direct sur le site internet du
Sénat
et que cette audition a été proposée
d'ailleurs par nos collègues
présidents collègues du Rhin et Madame
de La Gontrie excusez-moi j'aurais dû
commencer par Madame de La Gontrie de
l'année des marmas
[Musique]
et donc naturellement la pensée que
cette idée était intéressante compte
tenu du rapport que vous avez commis
alors certes c'est un rapport qui avait
été qui faisait suite une mission qui
vous était confiée par le ministre de
l'Intérieur de garde des sceaux en 2021
c'est un rapport qui date donc de
juillet 2021 mais il est évidemment
d'actualité puisqu'il a été rendu public
il y a quelques mois seulement il est
intéressant pour nous messieurs d'en
avoir connaissance bien sûr puisque sa
problématique est connexe à certains de
nos travaux et je pense notamment à se
relatif à la police judiciaire qui est
actuellement en cours et la formation
initiale est continue des forces de
police et de gendarmerie
et c'est aussi un complément utile au
débat que nous avons eu sur la loopmie
et qui a été adopté bien sûr récemment
l'accusation de discrimination est on le
sait souvent brandi par certains pour
mettre en cause la légitimité de
l'action de la légitimité pardon de
l'action des forces de sécurité
intérieure la discrimination dont font
l'objet les agents des forces de police
et de gendarmerie est en retour plus
souvent éludée alors qu'elle est aussi
réelle or l'un des mérites il n'y en a
pas qu'un naturel de l'étude que vous
avez menée messieurs avec l'assistance
de plusieurs corps d'inspection
d'ailleurs et d'une part d'avoir une
approche globale de la discrimination
dans le contexte de l'action menée au
quotidien par les forces de l'ordre en
abordant à la fois la question de la
discrimination qui peut être causée par
certains de leurs membres mais aussi de
la discrimination dans leur monde
peuvent être eux-mêmes les victimes soit
dans l'institution policière elle-même
soit de la part de tiers donc vous avez
abordé vraiment la problématique dans
toutes ces formes si je puis dire en
tous les cas sous toutes ses composantes
un autre mérite et d'autre part de
placer cette approche dans le lien
qu'entretienne les citoyens avec les
femmes et les hommes qui ont la charge
de nous protéger au quotidien un lien
qui nous en sommes tous témoins et pour
une partie de la population empreinte
d'une grande méfiance que le sentiment
d'une discrimination que certains se
plaisent à présenter comme systémique ne
fait d'ailleursiser terme de vos travaux
vous avez formulé une cinquantaine de
propositions dont un certain nombre
d'entre elles sont extrêmement
opérationnels voilà vous venez ce matin
détailler ces propositions et présenter
ce rapport je vais naturellement vous
laisser immédiatement la parole tout en
vous remerciant d'avoir accepté de venir
devant notre commission pour faire état
de ses travaux et finalement nourrir
notre propre travail notre propre
réflexion merci
peut-être le premier est bien très bien
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs merci de nous
avoir invité
Florian Roussel et moi c'est toujours un
honneur d'être entendu par le Sénat
je vais vous parler donc de ce rapport
la lutte contre les discriminations dans
l'action des forces de sécurité en vous
disant tout de suite que nous
n'engageons que nous c'est la liberté
d'un rapporteur à qui une mission est
confiée et qui remet un document à
l'autorité politique qui en fait ce
qu'elle estime de voir en fait ou de pas
en faire mais nous avons écrit ce
rapport avec nos examens et nos
investigations y compris sur le terrain
dans différents endroits de France et
avec nos notre liberté et parfois nos
convictions donc ça plaît ou ça plaît
pas ça intéresse ou pas le produit est
livré et ensuite l'autorité prend ses
responsabilités on entend souvent dire
que les rapports administratifs ne
servent à rien si j'en étais convaincu
je n'aurais pas accepté la mission c'est
la deuxième mission que nous faisons
ensemble le monsieur Roussel et moi la
précédente sur les suites de la loi sur
la transformation de la fonction
publique de 2019 à nous avons étudié la
manière de mettre en place la
négociation collective dans le respect
du statut et ça était suivi d'une
ordonnance et peut-être de d'accord
collectif donc là le tandem c'est
reconstitué pour traiter de la
discrimination je constate que dans le
paragraphe de 5 3 du rapport sur la loop
Miss et vous permettez l'expression
j'aime pas les acronymes enfin je peux
pour aller plus vite
quand même qui porte l'expression
renforcer la lutte contre les
discriminations et moi qui est passé
quelques années au ministère d'intérieur
et au ministère de la Justice je sais
qu'une phrase comme ça ne court pas
absolument les rues dans l'histoire des
textes de en tout cas du ministère de
l'Intérieur donc ça me réjouit de voir
que la loi le Parlement adopte les
documents qui reprend ce terme qui n'est
pas neutre qui quelquefois pose question
de la part des agents et dans le
paragraphe on voit des mentions qui sont
encore plus rares quand on regarde
l'histoire longue de la sécurité en
France la lutte contre le racisme
antisémitisme la haine anti LGBT et tout
type de discrimination c'est des mots
sont comptés et c'est dans un rapport
annexé à la loi que vous avez adoptée je
constate aussi que le rapport mentionne
un ministère qui doit ressembler à la
population alors là il y a un sujet que
j'ai pas le temps de développer mais qui
est à mon sens tout à fait essentiel
presque de nature constitutionnelle
puisque l'article 74 a avancé pour les
collectivités d'outre-mer un droit de
recruter en fonction de critères de la
population il y a toute une tradition
française auquel je suis attaché qui dit
le contraire qui dit le concours c'est
neutre et donc l'idée que je partage que
je partage et qui est dans le rapport de
faire attention aux dissociations
totales entre le visage d'une police et
la population à mon sens est une
décision de courageuse que j'avais pas
lu beaucoup jusqu'à maintenant il y a
quelques années j'étais à au balcon d'un
hôtel de Mexico et je regardais j'ose
pas dire en expert mais en tout cas en
personne intéressée l'arrêt d'une
manifestation sur une grande autoroute
occupée par des manifestants la totalité
quasi-totalité des manifestants et le
type en dun c'était pas le type argentin
blanc et les policiers étaient à 100%
type en daim aussi ça faisait réfléchir
sur ce cette problématique que vous avez
mis dans dans la loi je constate aussi
que il y a eu un changement à la tête
des deux inspections en général de la
police nationale et de la gendarmerie
nationale
nous de proposions pas de mettre des
magistrats à la tête ou comme adjoint
dans les inspections générales mais nous
proposons
de d'ouvrir ces inspections pour qu'il y
ait des professionnels de différents
ordres en matière de sécurité peut-être
plus qu'ailleurs la diversité pas
seulement d'origine mais aussi de
professionnels apportent quelque chose
pour la vérité et les forces de sécurité
ont un devoir de vérité j'y reviendrai
nous constatons aussi que plusieurs
mesures que nous proposions sont plus ou
moins déjà notre rapport vous l'avez dit
monsieur le Président date de deux ans
donc les choses ont tourné le
l'inspecteur général de la gendarmerie
me rappelait que nos propositions 2 dis
sont 16 17 22 28 sont plus ou moins déjà
mises en oeuvre ou à l'étude donc je le
souhaite comme tout rapporteur que les
nos propositions ne restent pas à l'être
mortes la discrimination c'est selon
l'article 225-1 du code de pénal
atteinte à la dignité de la personne je
retiens bien ce mot dignité et
porte sur l'interdiction de traitement
fondé uniquement sur des critères que
vous connaissez depuis
l'apparence physique jusque à la
prétendue race comme dit la loi
maintenant
évidemment la discrimination est révélée
par des traitements défavorables mais le
fait que la définition même ne porte pas
le mot défavorable peut faire réfléchir
faire des traitements à la limite même
favorable qui pourrait être discriminées
on peut y réfléchir je ne développe pas
il faut comprendre le rapport dans un
contexte
qui n'est pas neutre et qu'il faut avoir
en tête dès 1985 la revue sociologique
du travail consacré un numéro spécial à
la police et en étudiant ces process en
1989 j'avais l'honneur sur l'autorité
Pierre Joxe de contribuer à la création
de l'Institut des hautes études de
sécurité intérieure qui faisaient entrer
la recherche dans le monde de sécurité
et qui a prospéré
tous les gouvernements
jusqu'à sa suppression il y a trois ans
et son remplacement par l'iehemi du
ministère d'intérieur je souhaite
ardemment que cette présence de la
recherche continue et puis
le terrain que nous avons labouré
justement par un rapport de l'IHESI de
1991 le rapport du sociologue vivorka
sur polys et racisme
nous prétendons pas arriver dans un
terrain non du tout exploré donc il y a
toute une série de travaux qui ont mis
en alerte sur la nécessité absolue de
proscrire le racine dans les forces de
sécurité alors le paysage je dis un peu
le contexte et puis très rapidement on
reprendra les mesures mais vous les avez
sous les yeux par contre le contexte
mérite peut-être qu'on s'y arrête un
instant il me semble que depuis bien des
années le pays en matière de sécurité et
de devoir de la sécurité le rapport m'a
été confié parce que je suis déontologue
ministériel au sens de la loi Sapin de
2016 du ministère d'intérieur donc il y
a un lien entre cet aspect et le devoir
déontologique repris dans le code police
gendarmerie 2014
or en observant l'action des forces de
sécurité depuis longtemps il me semble
qu'on est partagé entre trois tendances
que nous avons bien connues au cours de
ce travail premièrement la célébration
des forces de sécurité j'ai pas le temps
de le citer mais je l'ai dans la main
mon texte fétiche c'est un texte d'un
sénateur pas n'importe lequel puisqu'il
s'agit de Pierre valdec Rousseau qui a
préfacé en 1896 un très beau livre sur
l'histoire du corps des gardiens de la
paix et une préface lumineuse que je
recommande à toutes et à tous de lire
sur Le Devoir
l'ingratitude de la population auprès
des gardiens de la paix et la mission
complètement diverse des forces de
sécurité qui ont à traiter des questions
totalement étrangères y compris le
maniement des foules ce qui fait
référence au maintien de l'ordre pierre
vadecrosso 1896
donc la célébration et le comme on
applaudissait les forces de sécurité
après les attentats il y a un premier
mouvement qui sait ce que la nation doit
aux forces de sécurité
la deuxième tendance à l'inverse et
chacun de nous est un peu partagé selon
les événements c'est l'accusation
j'en ai deux exemples qui que qui ne
quittent pas ma bibliothèque parce que
c'est des alertes auxquels il faut
penser l'ouvrage Médiapart ne parlait
pas de violences policières sous-entendu
par exemple beaucoup et le petit
opuscule de l'avocat William Bourdon
violence policière il y a tout un
courant dénonciateur qui dit aussi des
vérités qui font prendre en compte sinon
nous aurez pas demandé ce rapport et
puis mais à l'accusation
il m'arrive de penser toujours à ce que
waldeck-rousse disait dans la fin de son
artiste ici tu es les policiers tués
auxquels il était rendu hommage dans
l'ouvrage il se trouve que il y a 15
jours je traversais Romorantin je suis
un adepte de ce que disent les monuments
aux morts et au monument aux morts de
Romorantin côté des tués de la guerre il
y a un hommage à au gardien de la paix
Alphonse Robin tué en 44 à Jean cruchet
était tué dans son service en 1973 et à
Xavier juglet dans le nom nous est pas
inconnus abattu sur les Champs-Élysées
parce qu'il était policier et seulement
parce qu'il portait l'uniforme donc je
n'oublie pas le le
prix du sang chez la dans la police
nationale et la gendarmerie nationale au
rythme de 8 à 10 tombé chaque année
il empêche que quand il y a des
accusations de violence ou de
discrimination il faut y répondre et
troisième tendance j'espère qu'elle est
la plus répandue c'est la réflexion
l'observation là je renvoie à une autre
de mes Bibles le droit de la police qui
a pris maintenant quelques années de de
Jacques buisson qui est à la fois
professeur d'université ancien membre de
la Cour de cassation et ancien directeur
de l'école de la police nationale ça
fait quelques qualités pour observer la
la police ou bien je me permets de citer
mon propre ouvrage du juste exercice de
la force il y a trois ans où je parle
des sujets qui vous intéressent et sur
le contrôle de la de la police alors le
cette c'est une occasion
unique qui nous est donnée par si j'ose
dire 4 ministres puisqu'une première
lettre de mission nous avait été donnée
par Monsieur Castaner et Madame de
juillet 2020 puis ensuite les deux
ministres successeurs messieurs Darmanin
et Dupont-Moretti nous ont confirmés à
la fin de l'année
2020 cette mission
en premier lieu il est clair que
[Musique]
ce rapport a été fait que par deux
missionnaires qui croient que en
abordant les difficultés dans la police
ont la grandit quand aisant les
difficultés y compris les faits de
discrimination on prend des risques pour
la police elle-même et pour la nation
donc notre ligne c'est d'appeler les
choses par leur nom oui il y a de la
discrimination dans la police la
question et comment la déceler et
comment la traiter en deuxième lieu
le
n'oublions pas que l'article 12 du code
de procédure pénale dit que la
judiciaire est exercée sous la direction
du procureur et que l'article 15-2 du
code de procédure pénale prévoit des
inspections conjoines justice police
quand un officier de police judiciaire a
un comportement administratif
problématique
donc nous avons voulu associer c'était
une chose que j'avais demandé avant de
prendre la mission d'être missionné par
les deux ministères et pas par le
ministère de l'Intérieur seulement une
histoire là aussi en troisième lieu
nous avons voulu et et en discutant le
projet de lettre de mission nous sommes
allés dans ce sens nous avons voulu
traiter des discriminations commises et
des discriminations subies par la police
nationale il faut avoir discuté avec
certaines nous l'avons fait avec des
équipes de police de Marseille y compris
des policiers appartenant à des
minorités visibles qui sont accusées de
servir le pouvoir blanc
il y a il faut prendre en considération
ces choses qui sont aussi des des
troisième
c'était mon troisième point et puis en
quatrième lieu
nous avons voulu mener nos
investigations sur des documents et des
entretiens mais aussi aller sur le
terrain nous sommes allés en plusieurs
endroits Marseille Lille etc
passer des journées avec les forces de
l'ordre sur le terrain
je peux pas jurer que c'était nos
investigations sur le terrain étaient
absolument naturelles j'ai le souvenir
d'une visite à la gare de Sarcelles pour
avec une délégation la gare de Sarcelles
était à peu près comme si il y avait eu
un attentat il y avait il nous avait
entouré d'un nombre de policiers qui
faisait que pour parler un vendeur à la
sauvette ou autre il fallait traverser
trois rangs policiers donc je ne
surestime pas la vérité des instigations
mais on sent quand même des petites
choses y compris par ce qu'on ne vous
montre pas
et puis nous avons reçu toutes les
organisations syndicales que je pense
était très important qu'elle voit
comment on travaillait que c'était pas
contre elle et nous avons aussi discuté
avec plusieurs grandes organisations
défenseuses des droits humains
alors
le rapport ils sont son objet est de
nommer les questions par les mots justes
quand on commence à parler de la
discrimination c'est qu'on prend
conscience qu'elle est là
et nous avons travaillé sous le sous le
la houlette de
ce petit objet qui est la déclaration
des dents et du citoyen et de son
article 12 la force publique n'a de sens
que pour défendre les libertés alors
nous avons nous sommes allés rencontrer
les policiers et les gendarmes avec ça à
la main
le il est très important d'employer les
bons mots c'est ce que nous essayons de
dire dans ce rapport il y a plusieurs
années que je me bats contre le concept
de chêne pénal utilisé à tout à tout
bout de champ comme si le ce que le
ministre appelle le continent qui
pourrait faire l'objet de beaucoup de
discussions c'est pas l'objet mais que
l'action de maintien de la paix publique
parce que c'est ça qu'il s'agit était
une série de Mayons ayant le même sens
et la même dimension rien ne ressemble
plus à un maillon qu'à un autre or
l'investigation policière le déferlement
au juge et la mise en oeuvre de la
sanction par l'administration
pénitentiaire ou pas c'est pas du tout
une série de Mayons la justice n'est pas
dans le même du tout dans le même
rapport à la police que la police à la
pénitentiaire ou que la police à la
justice donc
nous faisons attention aux mots et
de vérité qui doit permettre de guider
les forces de sécurité
c'est une mission au service de la
liberté en appelant un chat un chat si
je puis dire
nous avons je vais vite nous sommes nos
54 propositions je les résume en 5 axes
Florian Roussel vous en développera
quelques-unes d'abord et ça rejoint ce
que je disais sur la recherche et les
instituts de de hautes études du
ministère de l'Intérieur actuellement et
de l'iachi avant
ce que j'appellerais le savoir vrai nous
développons beaucoup dans notre rapport
la manière dont les statistiques sont
faites
comment elles sont classées et donc
c'est très important c'est la
proposition 10 de développer la
recherche et le rapport à la science la
justice le fait le fait pas mal en ayant
renforcé son son potentiel de de
recherche
avec la mission en recherche Droit et
Justice et l'Institut de recherche de la
justice je souhaite et c'est une des
propositions de du rapport que le
ministère de l'Intérieur seul ou avec la
justice développe ce contact avec les
chercheurs c'est une manière d'aérer et
de prévenir des pépins nous
défendons les enquêtes de victimes qui
étaient faites par l'omdrp et qui
maintenant sont prises directement par
le système de recherche du ministère de
l'Intérieur la victimisation c'est la
perception des infractions elles aident
beaucoup à comprendre la sous-estimation
des problèmes que nous avions en charge
de traiter discrimination sont peu
nombreuses dans en tant que infraction
saisie par les systèmes de l'Intérieur a
fortiori par les systèmes de justice ça
veut pas dire qu'elle n'existe pas et
pour comprendre ce décalage les enquêtes
de victimisation sont à développer c'est
notre proposition 26 et puis
l'Observatoire de la discrimination que
nous proposons Florian Roussel va y
revenir donc ces efforts de statistiques
nous avons et nous avons
regardé les nattances la nature des
infractions poursuivies dans les
statistiques de la justice ou la
discrimination est dure à examiner elle
est souvent un facteur qui accompagne
une autre infraction une violence une
insulte une injure la discrimination
passe quelquefois
à côté de sa prise en compte parce qu'on
prend la fraction principale donc
premièrement savoir vraie il y a un gros
effort encore à faire pour avoir un
tableau de bord mais j'ai lu le rapport
annexé à la Love Me et je vois des
pistes intéressantes deuxièmement parler
vrai
oser poser sur la table et c'est pour ça
que je rend hommage aux deux ministres
et même aux quatre qui nous ont mandatés
ils ont osé dire allez voir la
discrimination y compris commise par la
police donc utiliser les bons mots ce
sont nos propositions 1 2 et 3 y compris
en étant à la disposition du Parlement
et en ce sens je vous remercie
doublement ce président de nous faire
venir c'est nos propositions
4 et 5 les associations proposition 7 et
le fait de ne pas hésiter
à travailler avec les organisations de
défense des droits de l'Homme j'ai un
souvenir lointain quand le ministère de
la Justice
de travailler à un guide de la détention
avec l'oïc c'est pas exactement le même
ton c'était l'occupé il y a 25 ans mais
c'est pas le même temps les productions
de mission de la justice et de l'eau IP
et pourtant
à un moment avait été réussi un guide
commun donc je ne désespère pas qu'il y
ait un travail commun la police et les
organisations de défense des droits
humains peuvent et doivent travailler
ensemble
enfin dans les jurys proposition 11 ça a
commencé déjà l'ouverture des jurys je
sors de trois mois comme vice-président
du jury de l'École nationale de la
magistrature sur sept membres qui
recrutait
260 magistrats il y avait deux
magistrats sur cette
alors on peut penser que c'est pas assez
moi c'est pas mon cas je pense que c'est
très bien que la magistrature soit
recrutée par des personnalités qui
viennent de différents horizons il y
avait un diplomate j'ai été voilà les
points de vue se croisaient et je
souhaite que ce une telle chose se passe
encore plus amplement pour la politique
troisièmement qualifier vrai je vous
parlais des nattances il y a une le
droit et donc la police c'est de la
qualification on vous fait entrer dans
une infraction ou pas la définition de
ces infractions et quelque chose de très
important notre proposition
13 pour enregistrer les procédures
pour position très et 24 tendent à
revigorer la qualification
discrimination qui est très dissolvante
de de la
j'aime pas ce terme de vivre ensemble
mais dissolvant de la volonté de vivre
en commun dans une société ordonnée
le quatrième axe répondre vrai quand il
y a besoin d'une réponse il faut la
donner et la discrimination ne peut pas
rester sous silence sous le boisseau
c'est un peu le thème de notre rapport
ça veut dire un accueillir les victimes
de discrimination j'ai vu que dans le
rapport Love Me et je n'aurais pas la
prétention de penser que c'est la suite
de notre rapport mais j'approuve dans la
lothmie les questions de d'accueil et de
confidentialité quand il y a 15
personnes dans la queue et que vous êtes
obligé de parler de de violence de
violence délicates qui touche à
l'intimité c'est insupportable je l'ai
moi-même
expérimenté en allant faire une démarche
dans un commissariat de police les
supermarchés prennent une précaution
avec une distance de sécurité ou la SNCF
je pense que la police nationale et la
gendarmerie qui ont pas attendu le
rapport pour aborder sujet mais nous
leur appelons donc accueillir ces les
victimes de discrimination sans les
décourager sans leur poser des questions
indiscrètes
autre que celle nécessitait par
l'enquête proposition 15 et 17
ensuite il est important d'avoir une
réponse interne nous ne sommes pas de
ceux qui disent la justice fera
l'affaire non la première responsabilité
d'un service administratif la police et
la gendarmerie en sont c'est de faire
leur propre police avec une hiérarchie
exemplaire qui s'est détectée les
phénomènes très en amont en nous a cité
l'exemple les documents en main d'un
service ou toutes les fonctionnaires ou
les militaires femmes partent
bon il y a pas besoin de d'être un grand
spécialiste de déontologie pour
comprendre qu'il y a un problème de
rapport de entre les sexes dans ce
service où les femmes sont peut-être
bousculées maltraités voilà donc ces
petits signaux qui les faciles pour un
chef petit ou un grand chef de ne pas
voir nous disons alerte
enfin
quand il y a mis en cause quand il y a
enquête sur un agent on a été sensible
au fait que la gendarmerie
faisait des des comptes à bout d'une
enquête il s'avérait que l'accusation
était mensongère ça vaut aussi au pénal
mais là je parle en disciplinaire et en
organisationnel il y avait des lettres
de mise hors de cause c'est à dire que
l'enquête se terminait on vous laisse
pas planer la suspicion en vous accusait
de discrimination on a fait une enquête
bon le chef dit après enquête et
enfin
la réponse disciplinaire et judiciaire
il nous est apparu souvent Florian
Roussel nous en reparlera que
la réaction pouvait être sous
proportionnée à la gravité de
l'infraction on a quelques propositions
en ce sens
je vois que au point de 7 du rapport de
la loopnie il y a quelque chose que nous
n'allions pas jusqu'à proposer c'est
l'exclusion automatique pour certains
délits l'exclusion du service pour
certains délits spécialement dans ceux
qui nous intéresse le racisme et la
discrimination nous disions ça autrement
il faudra mais ça c'est vous le
législateur voir comment une exclusion
automatique de service se met en scène
elle est pas impossible mais mérite
examen très précis enfin
dans l'action disciplinaire puis dans la
saisine du juge article 40 il y a
certainement un progrès pour ne pas
passer de
d'une insuffisance à un excès de saisine
à tout craindre de la justice dès qu'on
bouge une oreille mais une la
discrimination c'est la discrimination
ça touche à la dignité des personnes et
appelons les choses par leur nom
transmettons à au pouvoir disciplinaire
à l'enquête
igpn iggn
le la nécessité de réagir enfin je
termine si j'ai encore 3 minutes
monsieur le Président trois minutes pour
m'arrêter une seconde sur le contrôle
d'identité nous ne reprenons pas vous
l'avez vu la thèse développée par
plusieurs organisations et la commission
de consultative des droits de l'homme du
récépissé parce que après profonde de
réflexion nous pensons que ça aurait ça
n'atteindrait pas le résultat
attendu et que ça créerait
une difficulté dans l'exécution des
tâches en suspectant le policier qui
deviendrait une machine à débiter des
bordereaux mais pour autant nous pensons
que c'est un comme beaucoup de
sociologues que nous avons consulter
Fabien Joba ou ou monsieur Muana par
exemple que c'est un sujet
douloureux à la fois pour le public et
et pas n'importe quel public plutôt des
jeunes de minorités visibles que de gens
comme moi encore que l'autre jour dans
un quai de métro je vois un barrage de
policier de vigiles de la RATP qui
arrêtait des gens et j'avance avec un
petit sourire intérieur en disant voilà
un bourgeois comme moi il va passer
comme une lettre à la poste alors que
les pauvres gamins de 20 ans son
systématiquement arrêtés j'ai progressé
sur mon quai de métro avec une
satisfaction intérieure d'échapper à cet
humiliation et j'ai été le seul à être
arrêté alors que les gamins passaient en
ligne ça m'a fait beaucoup réfléchir sur
quand même une police républicaine qui
est
mais je dis ça parce que ça m'est arrivé
je n'en tire évidemment aucune
conclusion si ce n'est qu'il faut jamais
être simple dans ces sujets donc le
récépissé ne nous a pas convaincu mais
nous sentons et nous l'avons dit dans le
rapport et oralement avec les autorités
avec lequel nous travaillons nous
sentons que les choses sont en train
d'être pris en main par la justice et le
contrôle je vous cite pas les décisions
de justice que nous avons mis dans le
rapport mais quand la Cour de cassation
ou la cour d'appel de Paris en 2021
condamnent pour faute lourde l'État pour
contrôle discriminant parce que on
s'aperçoit qui avait été contrôlé dans
une classe qui revenait de voyage à la
gare du Nord trois personnes qui
appartenaient aux minorités visibles et
pas les autres attention nous avons dit
le il est évident que les choses sont en
train de changer la police et la
gendarmerie doivent prendre des
initiatives d'où toute une prix de
propositions qui chacune ne peuvent
paraître légères ou pas assez profonde
pour celles et ceux qui connaissent la
police et l'âge gendarmerie si tout ce
que nous proposons était mis en œuvre je
suis sûr que le visage du rapport police
population changerait à ce sujet je
recommande la revue après demain de 2020
qui s'appelle qui a été consacré à la
police et à la population dans lequel je
j'écris un article sur la police
peut-elle sourire est-ce que la police
est toujours obligée la gendarmerie
quand elle contrôle de faire comme si
vous aviez déjà tué trois personnes elle
peut contrôler les choses en expliquant
pourquoi elle contrôle d'un mot en et en
ayant un modus opérandit
de calme et de maîtrise voilà ce que je
voulais vous dire aussi rapidement que
possible avant de laisser la parole à
mon co-auteur monsieur Roussel
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs je tiens d'abord
à me joindre au président viguru pour
vous remercier de cette invitation à
venir nous exprimer devant vous
aujourd'hui alors pour ma part je vais
exposer trois pistes de réflexion que
nous avons longuement développé dans le
rapport la première qui porte sur
l'évolution des rapports entre les
forces de sécurité intérieure et la
société civile à l'instant la deuxième
qui porte sur l'évolution du traitement
administratif et disciplinaire des faits
de discrimination commis par les agents
et la troisième sur laquelle je serai
plus rapide qui porte sur une
proposition spécifique au droit pénal
alors sur le premier point le constat
que nous avons de rester dans le rapport
c'est le fait que les relations
s'étaient distendues ces dernières
années entre les forces de police de
gendarmerie tout particulièrement la
police à vrai dire et les représentants
de la société civile
la plupart des principales associations
les avocats les enseignants chercheurs
spécialisés
je me rappelle de nos interlocuteurs qui
a parlé de la police nationale comme une
forteresse assiégée
sont multiples il serait trop long de
les évoquer ici mais il nous semble en
tout cas que cette situation n'est pas
satisfaisante c'est évident et nous
avons évoqué plusieurs pistes pour
essayer je vous rappelle de nos
interlocuteurs qui a parlé de la police
nationale comme une forteresse assiégée
alors
les caisses sont multiples il serait
trop long de les évoquer ici mais il
nous semble en tout cas que cette
situation n'est pas satisfaisante c'est
évident et nous avons évoqué plusieurs
pistes pour essayer en référents LGBT
qui travaille à la préfecture de police
que nous avons rencontré mais peut-être
dans certains dans certaines
circonscriptions ne sont-ils pas
suffisamment valorisés connus etc alors
qu'ils peuvent parmi tous leurs mérites
il y a notamment celui de jouer le rôle
d'interlocuteurs privilégié des
associations
ce n'est pas spécifique à la France au
Royaume-Uni notamment c'est on compte
beaucoup sur tels interlocuteurs et
certaines associations je pense
notamment à une association de défense
des droits des Roms nous ont fait savoir
que c'était très intéressés par le fait
d'avoir un interlocuteur dédié sur ces
questions donc ça c'est le premier point
deuxième point c'est l'animation de
formation par des représentants
associatifs à destination des forces de
l'ordre alors là encore certaines
existent déjà c'est pas le mais
peut-être devrait-elle être approfondie
à différentes associations
par ailleurs pour les avocats et évoquer
aussi d'autres thèmes de formation je
pense notamment des formations sur les
cultures et les comportements associés
ça existe là encore à l'étranger
notamment en elle-même et ça permet de
prévenir certaines maladresses ou
certaines formes de stigmatisation lors
des contrôles et plus largement lors des
échanges avec les forces de l'ordre et
les populations concernent et puis donc
il y a cette proposition de création
d'un observatoire des discriminations
auxquelles serait associée les
représentants associatif alors il s'agit
de mieux évaluer ce phénomène de
discrimination à travers les carences
que statistique que nous avons pu
observer sur le sujet nous avons essayé
de recouper les signalements et tout
signalement confondu de discrimination
sur une année nous ont trouvé 12
alors que par ailleurs les enquêtes de
victimisation de victimisation
auxquelles vous faisiez allusion révélé
que 7% des plus de 14 ans déclarait au
cours des deux dernières années avoir
été victime de telle fûts donc il y a
tous colossal qui montre que il y a
différentes questions mais peut-être
aussi un problème entre autres
d'évaluation statistique évaluation
d'ailleurs aussi pour le ministère de la
Justice compte tenu des difficultés à
recenser les plaintes sur le sujet
et il importe donc il apparaît important
dans ce cadre que les différents
services mettent en commun leurs
informations échangent entre eux donc
police justice et puis donc en lien avec
les associations afin d'obtenir autant
que possible des données communes
consensuelles sur ce sujet ça c'est la
première piste que je voulais évoquer
la deuxième c'est donc le traitement
administratif est disciplinaire des
faits de discrimination alors il y
aurait beaucoup pas dire sur le sujet le
premier constat que nous avons fait
d'abord c'est que il y a une vraie
volonté de la hiérarchie aujourd'hui je
crois de mieux traiter ces faits de
mieux prendre lorsqu'ils sont constatés
à la fois de faire remonter les
signalements c'est tout l'objet
notamment des plateformes de
signalisation en ligne mais aussi de
mener dans certains cas des
investigations approfondies lorsque des
faits sont constatés et de sanctionner
les coupables
contrairement aux accusations qui ont pu
être parfois proférées il n'y a sûrement
pas d'impunité en la matière alors pour
autant il y a différentes pistes qui
nous paraissent devoir être et analyser
pour adapter encore mieux évoluer encore
plus faire évoluer encore plus cette
réponse disciplinaire
alors ce sont des pistes nous avons bien
sûr centré sur notre domaine
d'analyse à savoir la police la
gendarmerie et les discriminations mais
je crois que l'idée c'est que pour
beaucoup ça constatait plus général au
sein de la fonction publique voilà il
s'agit pas de dire que ce n'est vrai que
dans ce domaine précis le premier c'est
que peut-être les mesures de suspension
conservatoire là je parle en particulier
des faits internes au service n'était
pas aussi prononcer aussi régulièrement
qu'elle ne devrait l'être notamment
lorsque l'effet de harcèlement sexuel
par exemple
ont un lourd retentissement
psychologique pour les victimes pourrait
s'attendre à ce que soit plus nombreuse
et dans les dans les dossiers
individuels que nous avons consulté nous
sommes parfois étonnés qu'elle n'était
pas été plus régulièrement prononcée
de même vous y faisiez allusion nous
nous sommes étonnés du fait que les
signalements au parquet étaient aussi
peu fréquents alors que dans bien des
cas l'effet de discrimination constitue
très souvent des crimes ou des délits
donc qui doivent être signaler à
l'autorité judiciaire
à l'inverse
lorsqu'il y a une procédure pénale qui a
été engagée à la demande de la victime
il est parfois regrettable que
l'administration
attendent l'issue de cette procédure
pour engager des poursuites
disciplinaires alors qu'on pourrait
penser que les deux procédures doivent
aller de pair il y a pas besoin
d'attendre que le pénal tienne le
disciplinaire en l'état ça vaut pour la
police mais ça pourrait valoir pour
beaucoup d'autres administrations
quatrième point spécifique sa porte sur
les écoles de formation des policiers
des gendarmes nous avons parfois relevé
dans des dossiers des faits assez
sérieux de discrimination et nous nous
sommes étonnés de la réponse qui avait
été faite
dans certains cas on pouvait s'étonner
qu'il n'y ait pas eu de mesures
d'exclusion définitive lorsque les faits
révélé une inaptitude de l'élève a
exercé les fonctions alors ça j'ai pas
de dire que c'est général mais nous
avons retrouvé plusieurs cas précis ou
vu des données dont on disposées on
pouvait sérieusement sur le sujet
plus généralement dans certains nombre
dans un certain nombre de dossiers nous
sommes là encore interrogés sur la
réponse qui avait été apportée des fois
un simple rappel à la loi alors que
l'effet de discrimination par PC assez
sérieux dans d'autres une sanction qui
n'était peut-être pas aussi lourde
qu'elle aurait pu peut-être être vu des
données qui nous avait été communiqués
alors nous citons quelques exemples
précis dans le dans le rapport
j'assisterai peut-être sur un point très
précis sur ce point ça m'a frappé pour
les discriminations internes au service
c'est que bien des fois c'est la victime
elle-même la victime des faits de
discrimination lorsque c'est un agent
qui a dû obtenir sa mutation qui a dû
partir ailleurs dans une autre
circonscription de police l'auteur des
faits parfois il a été sanctionné et
c'est très bien mais lui il est resté en
fonction il est resté à son poste
le message envoyé n'est peut-être pas
satisfaisant
alors en ce qui concerne les faits de
discrimination cette fois-ci commis à
l'égard des tiers ce même constat
général peut aussi j'ajouterai peut-être
trois points précis le premier c'est le
traitement des signalements
les signalements parfois ils sont
directement gérés par les
circonscriptions de police au niveau de
chaque circonscription c'est normal ils
sont nombreux dans certains cas nous
avons cité des exemples qui venaient des
procédures elles-mêmes que nous avions
consulté nous ne sommes étonnés d'un
traitement parfois très succinct très
rapide alors que les faits qui étaient
remontés étaient assez précis et à tout
le moins dans la réponse voilà lorsque
il y a des faits bien et circonstancié
on ne peut pas se contenter de répondre
que la que la remarque que la plainte
est trop succincte et surtout lorsque la
plainte fait état d'un jeu raciste et
antisémite lors d'un contrôle d'un
contrôle de police on ne peut pas se
contenter de répondre comme nous l'avons
vu parfois ah bah oui mais le contrôle
était justifié vous étiez en infraction
que la route ça priori ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas acceptable d'autres réponses
ont pu nous sembler maladroites
notamment par rapport à certains cas de
d'accusation d'un jour homophobe
exactement
à droite et dans d'autres elle nous a
paru minimiser la réalité des
alors sur les signalements j'ajoute un
point c'est le traitement des
signalements par le Défenseur des droits
donc on va pas revenir sur tous les
procédures enfin nous avons comptabilisé
36 signalements en quelques années de la
part du Défenseur des droits sur ce
sujet aucun n'a donné lieu à des
poursuites disciplinaires ça paraît
étrange alors que pour les procédures
que l'on a vu sans vouloir porter un
jugement définitif dans certains cas il
y avait quand même des éléments
et dernier point la problématique des
lanceurs d'alerte qu'il ne faut pas non
plus sous-estimer
dans certains cas le lanceur d'alerte on
lui reprochait à lui aussi certains
faits et donc dans ces cas-là logique
qu'ils peuvent aussi poursuivi de sur le
plan disciplinaire dans certains cas je
pense à deux d'entre en particulier nous
ne sommes étonnés que la sanction que le
traitement administratif qui avait été
réservé au lanceur d'alerte avait plus
nous sembler plus sévère que celui qui
avait été réservé aux personnes qui
dénoncent cela nous a interrogé
dernier point très brièvement
l'adaptation du droit pénal alors nous
avons fait une proposition principale
voilà qui que je reviendrai brièvement
elle porte sur l'ingure non public
commise par les personnes dépositaires
de l'autorité publique alors
actuellement c'est un jour non public
pour toute personne
un policier comme moi vous c'est
simplement une contravention de 5e
classe qui est punie de 1500 euros
d'amende lorsque l'injure République
cela devient un déni qui est possible
d'un an de prison 45000 euros d'amende
alors le distinguo public non public est
très subtil il y a une jurisprudence
très développée de la Cour de cassation
je n'y reviens pas mais lorsqu'il s'agit
d'acte commis par des personnes
dépositaires de l'autorité publique
cette distinction n'apparaît pas
toujours pertinente est-ce qu'il est
plus grave de proférer un jeu raciste
dans la quand on est policier dans la
rue ou dans le fourgon dans le fourgon
de police par exemple
pourrait penser que les deux faits
appellent la même réponse pénale de même
la presse s'est fait l'écho ces
dernières années de plusieurs affaires
assez lourdes portant sur des injures
racistes antisémites répétés sur les
réseaux sociaux
avec un fort retentissement une forte
atteinte aussi à l'image de
l'institution et puis parfois des
sanctions disciples parfois la
révocation et c'est fait n'ont pourtant
donné lieu qu'à une poursuite devant le
tribunal de police pour une simple
contravention alors même que à la fois
il y avait une vraie atteinte à l'image
de l'institution une vraie atteinte au
devoir d'exemplarité de l'agent et puis
enfin on peut pas s'empêcher de penser
que lorsque les faits sont commis les
mêmes faits d'injures non public sont
commis à le contre à l'encontre d'une
personne dépositaire de l'autorité
publique cela devient attrait juste
titre un délit donc on peut penser que
la réciproque devrait être vrai aussi
donc voilà quelques brièvement exposés
quelques l'une des propositions de notre
rapport et maintenant je crois que la
disposition pour répondre à vos
questions
merci
merci Monsieur Roussel bien merci pour
cette présentation il y a plusieurs
collègues qui souhaitent intervenir le
premier d'entre eux étant Monsieur
Jérôme Durand puis Monsieur Alain Marc
Madame Brigitte l'airbier et puis madame
Benbassa qui vient de
monsieur Durand merci monsieur le
Président je vais très chaleureusement
remercier au nom de mon groupe
messieurs vigou et Roussel pour
le caractère de vérité la tonalité de
leur discours la tonalité du rapport qui
est très éclairant et qui à la fois
courageux libre et qui pose des mots
justes sur des réalités qui sont
complexes et vous n'avez pas minimiser
la complexité dans votre propre polymère
et puis remercier aussi le président de
la commission des lois qui a ouvert
droit à notre demande de d'audition
parce qu'il nous semble que ce rapport
qu'on a d'abord découvert par Mediapart
avant que le ministère de l'Intérieur ne
le rendre public peut-être aurait-il
fallu d'ailleurs que ce soit l'inverse
nous a paru justifier si intéresse
ce rapport il est danse il est riche il
est quasi exhaustif et puis ils
permettent des passionnés un certain
nombre de sujets qui nous tiennent
vraiment à cœur dans le groupe auquel
j'appartiens sur rapport police
population qui qui est au cœur des des
questions de fonctionnement de la police
républicaine des tiques la police
peut-elle sourire je trouve que la
formule est très juste et renvoie les
réalités qui nous marquent chacun alors
notre groupe avait défendu l'idée qu'on
pouvait
faire de
ces discriminations subies ou commises
par les forces de sécurité un indicateur
de performance budgétaire une secrétaire
d'état depuis démissionnaires avait
répondu
en séance c'est pas utile c'est déjà
dans les rapports igpn et iggn c'est pas
le cas et puis en plus ça n'a pas la
même porté notre collègue de Minati
avait donné un avis favorable pour la
commission des finances sur la création
de cet indicateur budgétaire on le
remercie donc l'amendement était passé
le ministre de l'Intérieur avait dit
qu'il était souhaitable que que ce
rapport puis cet indicateur puisse être
créé
est-ce que si on arrive à obtenir gain
de cause ce sera grâce à votre rapport
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner les
difficultés chez Vigouroux que vous avez
rencontré concernant le manque de
statistiques justement la matière et
comment on peut on peut approfondir un
peu ces données pour que elle soit utile
politiquement deuxième question que
j'avais à vous poser concerne les
contrôles d'identité vous avez écarté le
récépissé peut-être en deux trois mots
pourquoi
peut-être à l'aide de pas besoin
international et puis en séance on nous
avait indiqué
une ministre aux banques qui avait une
mission de la Cour des comptes sur le
les contrôles d'identité est-ce que vous
avez connaissance de ce sujet merci
merci monsieur Durand monsieur Marc
merci Président
vous avez évoqué monsieur le rapporteurs
les rapports entre ou du moins la
perception de la population par rapport
à sa police et à son gendarmerie et la
distinction qu'il y avait
entre entre les deux effectivement ces
rapports se sont distendus nous
sénateurs qui sommes sur le terrain
n'est ce pas et qui donc voyons à chaque
inspection de brigades annonce et à
chaque Sainte-Geneviève on ressent quand
même les efforts que font actuellement
les commandants de groupement sur la
direction du DGGN mais aussi pour ce qui
concerne la police des efforts qui sont
faits effectivement pour aller au plus
près des citoyens de façon à ce que ceci
est une meilleure perception de la
police et de leur gendarmerie d'autre
part vous savez que la qualité du
renseignement français qui était un de
nos fleurons il y a de cela quelques
dizaines d'années là aussi c'étaitompé
parce que ce rapport justement entre la
police gendarmerie et la population
étaient distendue et qu'il convient me
semble-t-il d'ailleurs pour la pour la
qualité de notre police de notre
gendarmerie que celui-ci sera fermé donc
des instructions me semble-t-il sont
donnés en ce sens je ne sais pas si vous
avez pu les mesurer d'autre part lorsque
l'on a des discriminations
supposées entre
les policiers les gendarmes et la
population notamment lors
d'interpellation ou de contrôle
d'identité un de nos collègues et nous
avons moi je crois ici à porter notre
part à cela c'est nous qui avons
préconiser les caméras piétons et
j'aimerais savoir si vous avez pu
évaluer leur efficacité ou si du moins
dans votre rapport vous préconisez
d'évaluer l'efficacité de ces dernières
qui nous semblent être quelque chose de
positif
merci Monsieur Marc madame l'herbier
sur ce que disait monsieur Vigouroux en
amont de tout ça l'intérêt de développer
la mixité
comme
la paix publique
au sein de la police
vous savez je suis élu depuis très
longtemps sur la zone Roubaix Tourcoing
et je suis universitaire et à ce titre
j'ai rencontré
un jeune à l'époque une vingtaine
d'années il s'appelait Abel Kader Haroun
c'est actuellement le commissaire
général de police de Roubaix et alors
Kader Haroun et le portrait type de
quelqu'un qui aurait pu déraper comme
beaucoup de jeunes de banlieue et qui
s'est raccroché à la police pour évoluer
pour se construire et pour construire
toute une famille il a créé les chemins
de la réussite c'est une association qui
aide les enfants et les jeunes qui se
sentent discriminés dans le cadre de
leurs études pour les aider à évoluer et
à accéder
tous les concours magistrats policiers
enfin tout ce qui existe comme concours
et leur dernièrement les mois dernier on
a organisé ensemble un col
au sein de la mairie de Tourcoing où on
a reçu les témoignages des jeunes qui
étaient rentrés dans la police beaucoup
beaucoup de jeunes d'origine maghrébine
d'origine de ZUP de classe sociale
défavorisées et ces jeunes étaient très
fiers d'être dans la police et plein de
d'espérance et de confiance en la police
et quand vous entendiez leur témoignage
on se disait quand même la police
comme la gendarmerie comme comme la
magistrature c'est vraiment une
possibilité mais surtout la police dans
ce cadre là un ascenseur social tous les
jeunes qui se sont exprimés de toute
évidence ils avaient dû passer de
nombreuses étapes avant d'arriver
à leur
poste de policiers même de base juste un
poste plus conséquent dans la police
alors tous ces témoignages
m'ont fait beaucoup réfléchir je me suis
rendu compte et de façon dans le cadre
professionnel universitaire je m'en
rendais déjà compte c'était très
difficile pour eux de trouver des stages
et on a créé un tutorat avec Kader
Haroun pour les épauler justement à
quitter le monde difficile
pour accéder à une espérance et de
rentrer dans la police
la seule chose que je voulais je voulais
insister là dessus c'est que forcément
il risque d'avoir des discriminations
ces jeunes parce qu'ils viennent de ces
quartiers les autres qui n'arrivent pas
s'en échapper forcément ils les ont en
cible souvent ce des cibles verbal ça va
pas beaucoup plus loin pour l'instant
beaucoup de cible verbales et
certainement des discriminations en
disant vendu enfin vous voyez tout ce
qu'on peut pourraient leur reprocher et
je pense que l'école de police de
Roubaix en a pris acte et ils font très
attention
épauler les policiers dans le cadre
d'une réaction potentielle et parce que
comment les degrés de réaction qui
peuvent avoir face à leur jeune qui
était juste avant leur copains de virer
pas toujours très positif alors
ce que j'ai remarqué aussi mais
j'attends de vous de confirmation ou pas
dans la gendarmerie je pense que on a
moins de de
réactions comme ça de parce que en
caserne ils sont plus encadrés dès le
départ tout jeune les jeunes qui
arrivent à la gendarmerie ils ont une un
encadrement très vigilant et qui évite
justement
de les laisser tout seul face à une
réaction voilà c'est ce que c'est
surtout là-dessus que je voulais revenir
et dans la magistrature c'est pareil
vous vous disiez aussi monsieur
Vigouroux que les jurys il fallait
élargir
le chant et moi je rajouterai aussi une
chose dans le cadre de des concours
évitez de mettre des des matières qui ne
correspondent pas à leurs origines je
m'explique par exemple si dans la
magistrature vous développez à outrance
la culture générale ces jeunes ils n'ont
pas de culture générale de base et c'est
très difficile pour eux en deux ans de
temps de récupérer tout le passé d'une
famille qui a été
encadrante pour les autres voilà ce que
je voulais vous dire et je vous remercie
les uns et les autres d'avoir abordé ce
sujet merci
merci monsieur le Président je voudrais
vous remercier pour ce rapport très
instructif et je voudrais faire quelques
remarques
concernant le contrôle officiels mes
collègues ont déjà
fait des remarques à ce sujet mais
j'avais déposé un texte en 2014 sur ce
sujet et je constate qu'il n'y a pas eu
une grande évolution pourtant on a eu
des travaux que vous avez cité de Jobard
Lévy et les vies etc etc
j'oublierai une parenthèse si on regarde
les chiffres donnés vous êtes enfin ne
sont pas nombreux les bourgeois blanc
arrêté n'est-ce pas très très rare quand
on regarde ces statistiques et depuis
ces travaux qui ont été quand même
complétés par des Américains qui ont
fait aussi un travail dans ce sens et je
ne vois pas d'évolution les caméras ou
pas le ré ou pas il y a eu des
expériences comme vous le savez en
Espagne dans une région il y a eu
n'est-ce pas il y a eu d'autres
expériences et aux États-Unis au Canada
il y a des expériences dans ce sens et
ce qu'on pourrait pas s'en inspirer et
arrêter ce facteur de discrimination et
qui est quand même insupportable surtout
qu'aujourd'hui avec le mouvement wok et
d'autres c'est disons ces contrôles de
faciès deviennent encore plus
insupportable et il faut il faut quand
même concéder c'est vraiment
insupportable des gens qui se font
arrêter plusieurs fois par jour parfois
etc et vous avez parlé très brièvement
de la formation et c'est vrai que nous
nous recevons d'une part du courrier des
élèves de ces formations des femmes
surtout qui se plaignent des femmes ou
issus disons
issus de l'immigration et disons combien
elles sont sujettes à des
discriminations et la liste est bien
longue mais assez classique je pense que
on n'a pas je me suis intéressé moins
que vous mais un peu on manque d'heures
de formation le nombre d'heures de
formation aux discriminations et aux
racisme dans ces écoles et n'est pas
assez importante
à ces importants et ensuite il faudrait
aussi faire faire faire des stages de
formation en faisant venir des experts
quand même parce que il faut renouveler
le la perception par la population de la
discrimination n'est-ce pas ce n'est pas
toujours la même avec l'évolution
actuelle et en même temps ce serait très
utile qu'il voit comment ce genre de de
lutte contre les discriminations se
déroulent dans d'autres pays comme par
exemple en Allemagne et aux États-Unis
voilà merci beaucoup merci Madame
et bien oui
du débat n'est
merci à tous les deux pour la qualité de
vos travaux merci au président buffet
d'avoir permis cette audition qui qui
semble nous avoir tous beaucoup
intéressé
je voudrais revenir sur sur l'ensemble
de l'utilité de ces travaux
lorsque nous avons interrogé le ministre
de l'Intérieur dans cette salle
d'ailleurs c'était Jérôme Durin qui
l'avait interrogé il nous a dit je cite
je suis très favorable conclusion du
rapport de Christian vigou déontologue
du ministère d'intérieur sur les actes
et propos racistes et discriminants au
sein de la police et je suis favorable
au changement je suis donc prêt à
travailler sur des amendements sur le
sujet par exemple dans la loopnie il a
évoqué le fait que ce rapport ne
proposait pas le récépissé pour le
contrôle d'identité
il a annoncé qu'il rendrait public ce
rapport et qu'il fallait avancer sur ce
sujet donc ma question elle est très
simple
quels sont les suites qui ont été donnés
à ces travaux puisque ces travaux sont
désormais un peu anciens
merci Monsieur tenue avec président oui
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur pour
vous vous développements je voulais
juste savoir si votre rapport a concerné
les outre-mer
ou la problématique des discriminations
existent et notamment une spécifique en
tout cas qui est vécu comme tel par les
intéressés
s'agissant du retour des originaires
comme on dit dans la police dans la
gendarmerie voir dans le pénitentiaire
les originaires lorsqu'ils sont mutés en
métropole et qu'ils cherchent à revenir
dans les territoires d'outre-mer et
beaucoup nous saisissent parce qu'ils
vivent
leur situation de non-retours en tout
cas dans l'immédiat comme une
discrimination
merci à chacune et chacun d'entre vous
bien monsieur le Président Monsieur
Roussel dans l'ordre que vous
souhaiterez
on va alterner
je voudrais d'abord dans l'ordre de des
prises de parole dire à Monsieur Durin
que
je dis une fois pour toute pour pas
avoir à le répéter malgré toute l'envie
que j'en ai je suis pas encore ministre
de l'Intérieur donc très sérieusement
les indices les les indicateurs c'est
très important et moins à titre
personnel puisque c'est uniquement ça
que nous pouvons faire
il nous semble dans l'optique de ce que
j'ai dit de qualifier et de mesurer et
de parler vrai
tout indicateur possible y compris dans
les papes et les documents budgétaires
puisque depuis la Golf c'est bien de ça
qu'il s'agit c'est de mesurer la
performance et bien dans un service de
force de sécurité c'est un élément de
performance la maîtrise de la Force et
de l'autorité parce que discrimination
c'est ça maîtriser la force sans jamais
empiéter sur la dignité de la personne
et bien c'est le cœur du métier de
police et si on trouvait un indicateur
moi je ou plusieurs indicateurs exemple
le taux de protestation c'est pour ça
que on
vante vraiment un travail statistique
je serai je pense que ce serait très
très
utile
les efforts fait en matière de
statistiques date depuis longtemps il a
fallu des années pour que le ministère
de l'Intérieur et ministère de la
Justice et des professionnels des
touristique à la tête de leur service de
statistiques il y a peu de temps que
c'est des inspecteurs général de l'Insee
qui sont d'un côté comme de l'autre
c'est une évolution que certains ont
voulu depuis des années on y est donc je
suis raisonnablement optimiste mais les
statistiques qualifiées en matière de
discrimination et on a demandé dans le
rapport que l'on affine les distinctions
qu'on comprenne plus la discrimination
dans un bloc
unique pour
Monsieur Marc sur la police et la
gendarmerie je vais laisser la parole à
Florian Roussel puis je dirais un mois
après
oui merci donc sur le sur cette réponse
à votre question monsieur le sénateur
deux points d'abord sur donc les le
souci de la police et de la gendarmerie
d'aller au contact de la population nous
en avons trouvé même des exemples j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure les difficultés en
lien avec les relations entre les
représentants d'association il revient
pas mais dans le sens que vous évoquez
il y a eu de nombreuses initiatives qui
ont été prises alors au niveau
institutionnel d'abord les partenariats
opérationnels etc donc les relations
avec les élus mais aussi au niveau du
terrain au niveau des intéressés
eux-mêmes je le souvenir en particulier
un échange très instructif que nous
avions eu avec le directeur
départemental de la sécurité publique du
Nord qui nous avait longuement
insisté sur son souci donc de le fait
qu'il reliait systématiquement à ses
agents le souci de à chaque fois prendre
contact avec les plusieurs sociaux avec
les avec les différentes avec les
commerçants enfin que la population que
la police soit vraiment au contact de la
population que les différents signaux
faibles de problèmes lui soient très
vite relayés et donc oui il y a beaucoup
d'initiatives locales qui sont
encouragées au niveau national de ce
point de vue et je crois que c'est
important encore une fois aussi bien
dans la police que dans la que dans la
gendarmerie sur les caméras piétons
alors notre rapport est intervenu un
moment très précis c'est au moment où le
nouveau dispositif de caméra venait à
être décidée peut-être mis en oeuvre
donc on en a pas vu les résultats
puisque c'est à partir de juillet 2021
je crois que on a pu on a pu le tester
ce dont nous avons été témoin par contre
c'est des très fortes attentes des
policiers des gendarmes sur le sujet il
y avait une vraie
tous déplorés la qualité très très
insuffisante du système ancien et tous
espéré vraiment que ces caméras
permettraient
[Musique]
je dirais que de savoir que je suis
filmé et je serai un peu révolté si je
ne sais pas donc là je suis pas sûr que
l'information madame monsieur qui
contrôlait vous êtes filmé soit toujours
suffisamment donné deuxièmement qui
allume est-ce que c'est en constante à
lui-même ou est-ce qu'on allume à
l'initiative du policier que dans le
fait du contrôle troisièmement qui est
un parce que ça arrive que un policier
le ton monte il préfère éteindre donc et
qui conserve et qui concerne pendant
pourquoi on conserve telle opération
telle caméra tel film de telle opération
et qu'on a fait disparaître tel film de
tel autre opération donc nous
recommandons cette technique mais ça
mérite examen
mais ça peut quand même créer un effet
quand la personne en face du policier
est informée qu'elle est filmée tous les
praticiens nous disent que le ton n'est
plus tout à fait le même
c'est ce qu'on prend en cible à Madame
l'herbier je voudrais dire que
l'expérience de Roubaix nous intéresse
c'est bien l'esprit que nous faisons
j'ai dit je n'y reviens pas que une
police ou une gendarmerie qui ressemble
à la population c'est nécessaire
spécialement en outre-mer monsieur le
sénateur mais en même temps il faut pas
commencer à faire des exclusions à
contrario parce que vous rentrez pas
dans les schémas des pourcentages moi je
n'emploie jamais le terme discrimination
positive mais par contre
aller chercher et c'est pour ça que j'ai
beaucoup d'intérêt à ce que vous avez
dit aller chercher comme un Sud le faire
la Troisième République ces élites ou
ces cadres dans des populations qui n'y
pensaient absolument pas et chacun en a
dans nos dans nos ancêtres même récents
des gens qui ont qui sont allés dans les
carrières de service public y compris de
sécurité parce qu'on est allé les
chercher il suffit pas d'être dans son
fauteuil d'attendre les candidatures
donc ce que vous avez dit je me permets
de dire que c'est tout à dans l'esprit
de ce que nous ce que nous cherchons
le
alors fondamental je l'ai vu encore
pendant trois mois pour la magistrature
mais j'extrapole pour la police qui est
notre sujet monsieur le Président ce
qu'on appelle pompeusement les biais
cognitifs évidemment à certains
candidats auxquels j'ai passé ces trois
derniers mois si on leur demandait le
dernier livre d'un auteur connu ils
étaient secs alors que sur les mangas ou
sur
tel autre production de grand public
actuels ils étaient incollables alors si
on refuse absolument ceux qui ne
connaissent pas Giraudoux dans les tous
les sens et qui nous bassine avec les
mangas effectivement la République se
portera mal donc les jurys la diversité
des jurys est l'orientation non pas vers
une série de connaissances qui doivent
avoir en matière de droit et pas de
doute mais pas seulement les
connaissances mais aussi du jugement du
respect des gens et ça ça se mesure dans
les concours et nous sommes c'est ce que
nous avons essayé de dire dans le
rapport
et enfin
enfin
Madame de La Gontrie ça serait bien un
prétentieux de dire que il y a déjà des
suites mais
il me semble que dans certains
dans certains
positions prises par le rapport de la
locmie ce qui est la décision la plus
récente c'est là que vous avez j'ai
retrouvé une série de choses qui vont
enfin dans lequel je me retrouve c'est
simplement une appréciation après
peut-être que je me trompe mais
le parcours de la victime page 60 le ce
que j'ai dit qui est délicat mais
nécessaire le fait que la police se
ressemble
relativement sans trop de dichotomie à
la population la formation alors le
rapport de la Cour des comptes
quand on a écrit le rapport je peux pas
en dire grand chose si ce n'est que
c'est très bien que la Cour des comptes
s'occupe de la formation des policiers
qu'il faut
rallonger surtout en formation continue
je crois beaucoup à la formation à
l'école ouverte aux organisations de
défense des droits humains pourquoi la
Ligue des droits de l'homme pourquoi
SOS racines ne viendrait pas rencontrer
les policiers c'est ça fait partie les
uns et les autres sont partis de la
société et il y a des expériences en ce
sens dont police le les caméras piétons
embarquées en en a parlé
il faut faire attention aussi à
ne pas
prendre sans précaution les outils
technologiques comme les drones très
qualifiés pour donc pour m'occuper de la
ville de Paris les nouveaux modes de
caméra sont quand même assez saisissant
à tous les sens du mot on peut voir on
peut lire le livre que une personne lit
à une terrasse de café avec une caméra
qui est à 50 mètres donc
les caméras embarquées en tout cas c'est
un moyen de pacifier le contact immédiat
entre la personne contrôlée le
paragraphe de 5,3 de la locmi sur la
lutte contre les discriminations le
[Musique]
le collège de déontologie qui est créée
l'exclusion comme je l'ai dit du service
ça va dans le sens de ce que Florian
Roussel vous rappeler sur le fait qu'on
a trouvé quelquefois que les sanctions
j'y vais avec prudence parce que pour
quiconque a exercé le pouvoir
disciplinaire c'est que c'est pas si
simple enfin on pourrait quand même
sans aller sur l'exclusion à tout coup
dire que quelqu'un qui a réitéré de la
discrimination il est pas fait pour la
police ou la gendarmerie la
prise en compte des questions
particulières à l'Outre-mer page 93 du
rapport que qui est joint à la loi que
vous avez adoptée nous avons passé un
moment nous avons voulu aller discuter
notamment avec la centrale outre-mer de
la gendarmerie nationale c'est-à-dire le
général qui s'occupe des et c'est vrai
que le pourcentage de force de la gendar
en outre-mer pose question peut-être que
quand il faut ramener la paix comme un
Mayotte l'autre jour il faut des forces
de sécurité mais dans le temps long je
trouve que ça interroge quand même dans
le rapport entre la sécurité et les
populations d'outre-mer qu'une part non
négligeable des forces notamment mobiles
de la gendarmerie soit en outre-mer et
le rapport de la locmi qui parle de
prépositionner des forces en outre-mer
va plutôt dans le sens encore alors moi
je considère que les forces mobiles qui
sont pas si nombreuses que ça dans le
pays doivent être utilisés que quand on
ne peut pas faire autrement c'est des
forces d'intervention donc je pense
qu'il y a une nous en nous en avons
parlé dans le rapport le rapport de la
locmi aborde le sujet et c'est bien il y
a un sujet particulier à traiter à
traiter ici
je vais certainement pas répondu à
toutes les questions mais
je note aussi que quand je vois cette
image
qui est une affiche sur les différents
types de discrimination que ministère de
l'Intérieur a développé avant notre
rapport je sais pas de tout ramener aux
effets du rapport qui est les 24
critères de discrimination pour avoir le
label Diversité discrimination de la
flore c'est pas c'est pas moi 15 ans il
y a ça je trouve que c'est c'est pour
avoir d'autres temps militaires et
obtenu que la Déclaration des droits de
l'homme soit affichée d'une part dans
les commissariats d'autre part dans les
prisons je pense que un affichage comme
ça qui dit les différents modes de
discrimination est utile parce que quand
on a fait une enquête au Conseil d'État
ça nous éloigne de la police enfin nous
connaissons bien cette maison tous les
deux sur les sujets de discrimination au
Conseil d'État dans le personnel et les
collègues les deux motifs de
discrimination majeure
ils sont là c'est c'était l'âge et
l'apparence physique on s'attend pas à
ce que donc il y a tout et ça peut faire
réfléchir les fonctionnaires
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
merci Monsieur Roussel de votre venue ce
matin et merci aux collègues évidemment
d'avoir assisté et poser des questions
merci à vous la séance est levée on se
retrouve cet après-midi pour l'audition
du garde des sceaux à
18h salle Monory
à tout à l'heure merci